hello to all viewers and listeners
this is an announcement for our episode
65.
yes martin some people told us that
it seems as if we're holding back the
horses
and we should let the rains go a little
bit
but we're living in very interesting
times and so
sometimes the time to say things to
speak
as martin luther said has come
and therefore if we want to loosen those
reins a little bit
we will have to go to the alternative
platforms correct
yes so i'm sure by now everybody knows
the drill
all the links for the alternative
platforms will be posted
in this video's description and also it
will be pinned
as a first comment in the comments below
and
uh it'll be aired in the normal time
slot nothing changes
except that you will push the links to
go to the alternative platform
of your choice correct as usual
on thursday at 6 pm south african
or central african time correct
thank you
you